my session was the context of Latin
America it's a context of growth
optimism opportunities there's a
contrast with the other parts of the
world the sources of growth and optimism
are essentially the expansion of the
middle class the expansion of the
domestic market and bringing people out
of poverty into the middle classes at
the same time of course the expansion in
natural resources that has resulted in
more value more exports and certainly
more economic opportunities foreign
direct investment has also played a role
and this brings a good momentum to a
region that has stronger democracies
greater role of the private sector and
at the same time a very optimistic
outlook so essentially i guess it's an
oasis in the middle of the world that is
debating about crisis there are some
lessons about how Latin America got here
and uncertainly 10 15 years ago we had
to undertake measures or austerity in
order to come to this stage of
prosperity so it's difficult to grow
without macroeconomic stability and
fiscal sustainability oh was that